[Music]
meanwhile an ottawa judge has granted a
10-day injunction to silence the
incessant honking from parked trucks on
the streets the decision comes after a
multi-million dollar class action
lawsuit was filed by a group of ottawa
residents they argue the prolonged noise
is causing permanent harm
so what does this decision truly mean
and how will this injunction be enforced
joining us now is litigation lawyer fred
schuman fred we appreciate you joining
us a bit of a complex issue in many in
many respects but let's begin with the
basics the injunction came out of a
class action lawsuit what exactly does
this mean
so an injunction is just a court order
that tells somebody they have to do
something or that they can't do
something
it can be enforced by the police
arresting somebody for contempt of court
and it lasts in this case for ten days
so uh that's what the court has ordered
the court is essentially ordered in this
case that you can't use a horn in
downtown ottawa unless you're a fire
truck basically all right so there are a
lot of trucks uh potentially a lot of
protesters as well so let's talk about
is this even enforceable given the
situation
well i i mean
yeah it's it's enforceable there may be
difficulties with enforcing it i mean
remember it's an anti-honk injunction
it's not an anti-protest injunction and
i think as most classroom teachers know
if somebody makes a noise and you're not
watching them at that very moment it can
be difficult to
to tell who made the noise
so there may be practical difficulties
with actually identifying somebody and
convicting them of contempt of court but
the order authorizes the police to
arrest people uh if they have reasonable
grounds to believe that they've
contravened the order by honking so that
may be something easier for the police
to
to manage and form those grounds um but
the latest reports i've seen have
suggested that the injunction has worked
not because it's being enforced but
because people simply seem to be
complying with it and and not honking
so i mean actual enforcement isn't
always necessary sometimes people just
do what the courts ordered them to do
voluntarily what's interesting to break
this down is this is a civil suit this
isn't a criminal court that is deciding
this so you kind of wonder where this
could go i mean the honking is one thing
but even beyond this this is a class
action lawsuit
9.8 million dollars is what they were
seeking in terms of damages um so the
few layers to this but how long could
this process take you know from the from
the plaintiff's point of view
well that depends i think if the
plaintiffs are really interested in in
pushing this all the way to a trial or
something like that i mean class action
lawsuits can take years to actually come
to that final stage but i'm not sure
that the plaintiffs are really
in this for the long haul in that sense
i mean if i were representing the
plaintiffs i think i would have been
interested in starting a class-action
lawsuit not because um i necessarily
want to go to trial not because it's
necessary to get the injunction you
don't have to have a class action
lawsuit to get an injunction like this
but to to make the threat that was made
a few days ago of um
large money damages against the
protesters so a few days ago there was
this threat by the plaintiff's lawyers i
don't mean threat in a to criticize them
but they were simply saying if you stay
here and you continue these activities
you are going to be a defendant in this
lawsuit and you're going to potentially
be on the hook
for um a very large amount of money
damages because the damages are being
suffered by everybody in the area and
they were offering to release the
protesters legally from that lawsuit if
they left and so the class action
tool was useful in making that threat
credibly and offering people a release
if they left but it is at the end of the
day just a reprieve so this injunction
in effect for 10 days do we have a sense
what happens after that
yeah so in 10 day where in nine days the
plaintiff's lawyers will go back to
court back to the judge who who ordered
this injunction and remember there were
some there was one lawyer there named
keith wilson who represented some of the
protesters uh perhaps the organizers i
think so he was there he opposed the
injunction yesterday
and um they'll be back before the judge
in nine days
to seek and the plaintiffs will be
seeking an extension seeking to continue
that injunction and they need to do that
because
the judge wasn't satisfied that all of
the protesters had notice of the motion
for an injunction so they didn't all
know that this was coming to court they
didn't all have the opportunity to be
there yesterday and tell their side of
the story so the judge is only allowed
to make an order that lasts for 10 days
so but he's already booked the return
date which is coming back to court the
plaintiffs will say we want another
10 days or you know we've done all these
things in the interim we've um
broadcast the order on the on the tv and
amplified it uh and you know you should
grant an injunction now for a longer
period of time well this could take a
while in a number of court cases we
appreciate this fred schumann litigation
lawyer we appreciate your time sir
thanks very much for having